in a few hours kentucky's attorney
general will give recordings of the
briana taylor grand jury hearing
to a judge daniel cameron now says he
never recommended murder charges in the
case
the grand jury handed down no charges
for taylor's death
and one of the jurors is asking for
permission to explain
why we're now learning more about that
request adriana diaz is in louisville
adriana when will the public be able to
hear these recordings
anthony the judge ordered that the
recordings be filed in court by noon
today
the state attorney general said
yesterday that most of the recordings
will be made public
but it's unclear how or when that'll
happen once the court has them
and the grandeur who's petitioning the
court to speak publicly says they want
to talk about what might not be in those
recordings
possible charges or defendants not
presented
[Music]
protesters and briana taylor's mother
tamika palmer
have not stopped demanding justice
especially after kentucky attorney
general daniel cameron admitted
he never recommended murder charges for
taylor's death
ultimately our judgment is that the
charge that we could prove at trial
beyond a reasonable doubt was for one
endangerment
against mr hankinson former detective
brett henkerson faces
three counts of wanton endangerment for
shots fired into a neighbor's apartment
he has pleaded not guilty in an
exclusive interview with wdrb-tv
cameron said that while some feel
justice was not served he says the facts
won out
i cannot fashion the facts in such a way
to meet
a narrative that in many ways had
already been put out there before the
facts have been put out there
we continue to ask for poor transparency
taylor's family attorney ben crump says
the upcoming release of the grand jury
recordings is one small step
toward justice we at least want to know
that it's equal justice under the law
for
black people as victims not only when
black people are accused of crimes
the other two officers who fired shots
at taylor including the bullet that
killed her
miles cosgrove and jonathan mattingly
were not indicted on any charges
the attorney for the anonymous juror who
wants to speak out says his client felt
compelled to take action
after how cameron presented the grand
jury findings last week
is there a concern that if these filings
are released it could set a precedent
for future grand juries
where grand jurors won't be able to
trust that their proceedings remain
private as they
are meant to it would be more dangerous
to set a precedent
to not disclose everything to the public
that you're allowed to
louisville's incoming interim police
chief yvette gentry the first woman in
that role
says one of her first orders of business
is regaining trust
i think you have to acknowledge that
some of the reasons why
they don't trust it is because some of
the basic information
has been skewed and i understand what it
feels like to be angry and neutralized
and upset
both from what the protesters are
feeling and the officers as well
the grand juror is asking for more than
just the recordings to be released they
want all
transcripts and reports to be made
public as well now we don't know when a
judge might rule on the grand jurors
request but their attorney says he's
hopeful that could happen
within a couple weeks tony all right
adriana thank you very much this is kind
of a high stakes release for attorney
general cameron
uh because president trump has called
him a star he's a mitch mcconnell
protege his political career could be on
the line here in some ways
you know yeah but the fact that this
grand juror said listen i want to speak
i want the public to know exactly what
we saw or what maybe what we didn't see
is very very important yeah and the
argument for transparency is
a very compelling one i see it as a
positive direction in getting answers in
this case
i agree very exciting